launching new research Into the Depths
to discover more about ocean carbon
these scientists are part of the convex
Seascape survey
grabbing mud from the sea floor to
analyze the tiny creatures within it and
quantify how much carbon they can move
and store
of the 2500 Marine invertebrates in UK
Waters only 10 have been studied in
depth this team hopes to change that
what we're trying to understand as a
wider question is the role that small
marine animals that live in bird mud
play in the flux of carbon between
what's in the water and what's in the
sediment so we're probably only talking
about a 10 to 15 centimeter of that
benthic mud at the bottom of our oceans
biggest habitat on our planet and we
really don't understand how important
the animals that live in that sort of
layer Between the Ocean and the mother
in moving carbon between those two
ninety percent of the Seas biodiversity
lives in this sediment creatures like
the brittle starfish and the spoon worm
in their burrowing and building some
will remove carbon others will release
it
best estimates are that Coastal Waters
like these and the sea creatures that
live in them could provide six percent
of the carbon drawdown that's needed to
slow the rise in global temperatures to
1.5 degrees now that's the same as
closing all of the world's cement and
chemical Industries
this is first of its kind science and
back in the lab the 19 different species
they found are studied individually
using fluorescent sediment to measure
their activities and how they impact
carbon levels the next step is to
identify how vulnerable they are to
human activities we have 13 Partners
some in South Africa and Argentina South
Georgia British Columbia and the UK and
really we're all working together to
quantify and produce reliable scientific
data to have a better understanding of
how carbon is stored in our sea floors
the ocean has absorbed about a third of
the carbon dioxide that humans have
emitted into the atmosphere since the
beginning of the Industrial Revolution
but there is no policy currently
protecting carbon storage in the ocean
once deeper benefits of the Seascape are
known better protection can follow
Charlie Angela Al Jazeera Cumbre
Scotland